hey what's up guys we are about to film
the last dope as usual episode of the
year not of the season but of the year
marty and i are going to be hanging out
rosie already took the car so i'm good
not to drive so i wanted to take some
mushroom capsules but if i take the
mushroom capsules on camera during the
podcast they might not even hit me until
we're done filming so marty please blur
this out i am taking these capsules i'm
gonna take two of them that's 1.4 grams
of some mushrooms but let's take them
and have a dope ass day
let the intro start
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo
what's up guys welcome back uh this is
the dope as usual podcast my name is
thomas topazio this is marty o'neil
what's up what's up what's up guys
how you doing how you feeling it's
another episode it's a new episode and
if you're here with us on the first day
it's monday it's three o'clock at
pacific time thank you for giving us
your time your attention please drive
safe thank you for hanging out with your
friends and watching us thank you for
recommending us to your friends it's
the end of the year
marty
is it
this is oh man i was this is it yeah
yeah no cussing yet i'm trying my best
to be on top of it and try not to say
words
let's just take a moment and check out
the lights
sizzling yeah sorry if you're if you're
listening to this we got a whole new
light set up shout out to my homie trent
um he put in all the poles in the
ceiling you can't see
we have all our light yes
exactly we have all our lights set up as
you can see the backsplashes we're gonna
make them a little heavier we want them
to so when i smoke it just
you know when you're smoking it in a
room and the sun's going down and that
beam of light comes through catch your
smoke and everyone's infatuated with it
that's what i want every episode
every exhale if i move back just bleed
in on me oh it's going to be bomb
so real quick yes you notice the changes
it looks like this is glowing this is
straight glowing
i love it the set looks bomb we need a
little more lights but we're we're
upgrading okay guys
this the end of the year this is the
last episode of 2021 marty we started in
2021
started 10 months ago
a little less than 10 months ago guys
we're doing good we're doing great it's
because of you guys thank you so much
first off
thank you so much for hanging out with
us and
just chilling with us okay
with that being said let me roll right
into this episode because this episode
is going to be
slightly different because i'm not sure
if i'm gonna be able to
no i'll hold it together but let me let
you in on a little secret
i'm on mushrooms
i hate mushrooms
so this is what's going on today guys
marty and i said you know let's leave it
off with a bang as you can tell from the
intro
of this video
i took some capsules because you can't
just eat mushrooms unless you're mike
tyson and logan paul you're allowed to
do whatever you want
but uh over here in our side we get
deleted a lot because we're on it yeah
we get it
the shroom tech yeah
what are you talking about for i'm just
saying oh it's as far as youtube's
concerned those [ __ ] for sure oh it was
stream tech on it oh okay i get you like
bro
no
because mike tyson just showed mushrooms
on on youtube but he is mike tyson but
we can't do that all right we are
the black sheep
of the internet all right while still
allowing us to be here they're also
going hey don't look over there don't
even look at this section okay i know
there's a lot of views just don't look
that's what's going on so who cares
it's fine anyway these capsules have not
kicked in yet i took them like 40
minutes 30 minutes ago i'm just waiting
for them to hit me
that's what this episode's gonna be
about in a little bit i may or may not
eat some mushroom chocolates but uh i
don't have a car rosie took the car i
don't have to drive i don't have to do
anything responsible
except lock the door to the warehouse
when i leave today that's all i got to
do in terms of responsibility so guys
aside from quarterback an entire episode
yeah that's different i'm talking about
responsibilities like [ __ ] might get
stolen yeah if i leave the door open but
um
this is where we are this is the end of
the year let's do a quick recap and get
right into my topics
since since you begun
since the last time i saw you guys
well no every every time we do it's me
me and you episode
it's not really a solo episode you know
what i'm saying we talk about everything
with us
so recap marty episode
the one we did with you
how you feeling
[ __ ] weird kind of still foggy
it felt really amazing i felt it felt
way different than when my dad died
going through it with this whole
community it made it like it took a lot
of the sting away just knowing like i
got so many people's stories so many
people relating to the episode that it
just
there was a lot of like good feelings
mixed up in
when when somebody dies it's just it
[ __ ] just hits you it's just shock
when we did the episode i hadn't even
really felt it yeah it was less than 24
hours yeah that and i knew that like
that's why i knew that was the only time
we could do it just surprised when you
said yeah let's do it oh [ __ ] let's go
yeah it hadn't even probably still
hasn't hit me yet definitely not it's
like
after the holidays you'll be thinking
mm-hmm
that's good though yeah but thank you to
everybody for showing april so much love
that she was the next one april episode
oh yeah i'm [ __ ] skipping episodes
but like thank you she really i
appreciated that she appreciated all the
love that was a huge feat to get her on
here and together talking about herself
she didn't want to do that at all yeah
it took a long time it's not like we're
ever come on come on we need you and
it's never been that we asked her eight
months ago and she goes oh no we asked
for six months good no
that's not her thing she's not like the
internet person but the fans wanted it i
knew it'd be an awesome episode i knew
she her story could inspire people so
that and she's
very much your
just yeah
girl version
i'm telling you i'm listening to these
stories and it's like
you tell great stories i'm stuck
listening and imagining you punch
somebody in front of a bar and
seeing you get punched in the face too
like i could see all of it so i thought
it was a great episode yeah yeah i'm
really i'm just so grateful that it came
out like that and everybody liked it and
it was a great reaction she felt great
about it
there was some things we had to take out
just because it's like
there is no upside for her to come out
here and just talk about everything i
know
maybe one day how about this we're all
super rich and she doesn't have to rely
on like well what if they don't want to
buy a house for me because of this story
we'll have a part two and then we'll
have a part two
we get really rich and not have to worry
about that she's obligated april you're
obligated i know you're watching this
you're obligated to come back on and
tell that story because that story
was ridiculous jay even asked like
what'd you cut out and i told me because
what
you cut that i go i know right it's like
a joey d that's a white woman's body
right here
what'd you just say
uh that was the craziest thing of the
episode and then when we watched it oh
wait
where is this
i understand okay i get it that was her
first time even up in the warehouse
because it's the first time she's ever
been her family's in town for this week
so it was really literally the first
chance we had to bring her up here and
just to her getting like comfortable and
you know it's it's cool because that is
the whole team like when we took that
picture of the four of us like that is
the podcast yeah and she's been like a
recurring character she's never had
everybody got to meet her now yeah i
read through all the comments everybody
just like damn she's kind of harder than
marty is
yeah i could see i could see that
if you want to go pound for pound yeah i
get it yeah a lot more yeah venom i had
to assert my dominance early on and [ __ ]
i remember literally we were putting
together ariana's crib it was the first
time we had ever assembled something
together we
started craigslist and [ __ ]
and we started like arguing it was the
only moment ever in our like history
where like i put the thing on i'm like
what the f like i felt like we were
about to fight
like putting together ariana's crib
hysterically
but you know that was the after that
she i don't know i think she always knew
anytime i think she always wrestled
around i had to let her know earlier
none of this [ __ ] is going to work
outweigh her yeah no that's what i'm
saying i don't i don't want to have to
prove this [ __ ] other than that she
might got you i don't know with the
willpower in her head
man i'll punch your fist with my face
kind of willpower she has yeah no she's
got some [ __ ] willpower on her don't
get me wrong but i just had to let her
know yeah i just said you know how to
let her know by putting all my [ __ ]
weight in your collarbone and going do
you want this again
not for real guys i'm just talking [ __ ]
very hypothetical just kidding
people think you're a woman
yeah not on here
on this show yeah no she's
she's a lot of woman
i thought it was a great episode yeah it
was really fun in the chat just sitting
there going oh my god you guys finally
get to see april i bet all her [ __ ]
friends were cheering and [ __ ] i can't
imagine oh my god it's so funny because
we had to put that intro in because we
after we filmed she goes you guys didn't
say anything positively
we didn't talk she's such a not trashy
person no she's so like let's bring up
your awesome
most trashious events in your life yep
that's exactly what you did
sorry that's kind of what the show is
about but yeah we'll get into the good
so that's why we have the intro guys
because we we coasted right over like
the success the accomplishments we just
got into just the life and the drugs and
just kind of left it there for that
episode
but it's okay we're here that was marty
episode the april episode and rosie was
right before that let's go we did talk
about the rosie episode didn't we i
think so
thank you guys for watching that was fun
she was super nervous just as nervous as
april was
and uh it went great everything's going
good you guys have
seen rosie for 10 years and finally got
to hear some of
how she started you know how she grew up
because rosie when i first met her man
i couldn't believe like you said i felt
like a piece of [ __ ] going to her
family's house
like yo am i the bad one here oh my god
they're all church going
christ-loving you know church-goers i
don't know what else to say
uh but yeah i just i felt the same way
you did like
okay and then because her last boyfriend
her dad doesn't like nice so
and he's one of my childhoods shout out
to shitty ex-boyfriends thing is he was
just a bad dude as a boyfriend because i
knew him growing up and i didn't know i
know who did you
date before me
who
i'm like oh you should crack him in
football i remember him that was my
friend
and then like wait
he did what oh man now i can't like the
guy anymore but it's uh it's in the past
like i don't i truly don't give a [ __ ]
it's been forever like you like yeah
yeah there's a bad guy before me man
psychotic ex-boyfriend you know so um
yeah thank you guys just wanna do a
recap real quick marty
some update came and now all my notes
are gone
okay cool okay so yeah i can't see
anything uh guys thank you so much if
you haven't seen that it's called the
rosie episode dealing with death part
two
growing up too fast with april o'neil
marty's wife all you know what all of
december has been like just us
rosie episode marty episode april
episode solo
hey
it's a good this is a good month i love
guests
love having guests on
rather do a solo every time but it's
okay because i love talking to people
which gets me on to my next topic
you guys we talked about it so you guys
have been dming me like crazy you've
been in the comments
let me just clarify something
today was supposed to be adam 22 the no
jumper
uh host atom22 well actually
sorry to interrupt what
[ __ ] last week was supposed to be him
oh okay sorry last week was supposed to
be him and he canceled he was supposed
to be the april up april was supposed to
yeah he's supposed to be there but he
canceled um
as i'm sitting here which is whatever
he got busy but uh he cancelled
yesterday again
so guys we did everything we could if he
ever comes on the show he comes on the
show if he doesn't just know
we were there we tried our best we did
everything got prepared
sat here rolled joints
the whole shirt
but i know your wife's pregnant you're a
famous dude you have a little baby i can
two of your friends died in the past
week both of those rappers were as good
friends so i understand like you're not
coming to the random guy's show i get
that we just wanted to clarify
why he's not here it's not because we
all got an argument or a fight it's
because
we just cancelled so we if it ever
happens
to booking agent yeah oh yeah not us
booking agents talk to each other and we
didn't
there let's just leave it at that guys
um we get it it's not like i'm gonna sit
here and go you're a [ __ ] pete no
[ __ ] happens i understand i don't know
your situation we just don't want to
disappoint them yeah we just don't want
the fans to be like what the [ __ ] bro
where's it at that's why okay so if it
happens it happens it'll be next month
larry lawton's coming next month dr
drew's coming next month i'm not gonna
even say who the [ __ ] else is coming
next month because you know who i'm
talking about
a lot of guests coming to 2022 okay so i
[ __ ] forgot about them i know i know
because i've been too excited i only
want to talk about it i only told like
two of my [ __ ] homies
we officially can't say like you can't
say anybody's gonna say anything before
it happens anymore never no more i feel
too shitty if it doesn't happen i know
but anyway guys that's what's going on
that's why the atom22 episode is not yet
last week or this week so it's been all
us this month which has been super
[ __ ] fun
guys thank you so much for watching
let's get into this episode okay let's
start i don't feel these capsules but
it's okay i was about to say can we let
it joint as i'm staring at you
okay let me do this let me let oh
what can i get that lighter yep
just start
on air on air
there we go
um here we go guys uh that's the recap
of what's been going on i ate the
mushrooms
let's see if they hit me i hope they do
but they're it's only 1.4 grams so
it might not be the craziest but let's
go guys a solo episode let me get into
some topics which we have not done uh
in a minute trending actual pop culture
thing not pop culture but things that
are going on in the news you know what's
crazy i want you if you ever
tell your brain
to start typing on our pages
about some [ __ ] that you think we should
know
just [ __ ] stop
like when people bash me for not knowing
[ __ ] just i don't [ __ ] care i didn't
even know about it you think i'd give a
[ __ ] about your opinion about it i truly
don't so this is what i'm talking about
somebody said a word online yesterday uh
is it like a new company apparently this
new covet variant
i didn't know what it was and i was a
piece of [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] about
people
all this stuff apparently because i
don't know about it
i don't watch the news
you guys know that i don't look at
anything i don't give a [ __ ] leave me
alone i got so much [ __ ] to do
if i can help i'll help
other than that [ __ ] leave me alone
your comment just means
nothing to me
instagram has a block button and a block
of other accounts they may make
i've been using it heavily so just let
you guys know
don't give a [ __ ] on to the topic that's
why i brought this up because
i forgot joe biden as our president
not kidding at all we go the [ __ ]
president go
i thought you said joe biden that's
right joe that's not your button it's
not your button
okay no it's not joe button
so yeah i forgot i had to think for
about two seconds oh yeah that's right
that's right that was the last year's
season of uh america
the last episode of the sitcom
um so that's what's going on this
[ __ ] all i know about joe biden
is he's pretty much
has full-blown dementia the man can't
finish a sentence
it's like he's on mushrooms
that's cool i can make it i'm doing a
show on mushrooms over here they haven't
hit yet but you know
so this man this morning decided to
freeze all student loan payments until
may 1st 41 million dollar buyout or
hold out whatever you want i don't
[ __ ] know
either way if you have student loans and
you're dying and not staying afloat to
pay back the loans that should be free
to get educated
first off
froze until may 1st which is a huge help
that's like telling people no you don't
pay your water bill this month like
thank you [ __ ]
so i don't know if you have to pay it
back but
that's what's going on that's one thing
in the news i saw where i said you know
what about [ __ ] time do something
productive thank you because college
students go to school for work they
can't
get jobs they're at school but you want
them to pay like they're at work
makes no sense so that's one thing and
what's good
but not really what's good
it's it's what's supposed to be done
what's should have been done so what's a
small highlight in a shitty situation
small highlight a shitty situation
that's perfect way to put it
um
let's get into this next topic
i know it's been a minute i know marty i
know you probably have no idea who this
person is because you have
multiple responsibilities
there's a guy named right house
rittenhouse right now i don't remember
his name kyle
the kid that shot people okay so this
[ __ ] white kid shot some protesters
during the protests black lives matter
[ __ ] why do you have a gun i have no
idea why you have a gun in public just
asking for it
i have no idea it's like this you know
how you know what
you know how pieces of [ __ ] are like the
way she's dressed she was she was asking
to get assaulted like
stop
first off
because you have to look at both sides
the what the man piece of [ __ ] saying is
you're enticing [ __ ] to stare
at you and want to molest you you know
what i'm saying
but why can't a girl wear the what the
[ __ ] she wants without having to worry
about being molested
it's completely true
it's it's they shouldn't have to be
worried
ready
same thing not the same thing but here's
my comparison to this kyle [ __ ] and a
lot you just compared
people being assaulted by people being
sexually shut the [ __ ] up okay listen to
my comparison before you get on me
he's allowed to have a gun it's legal to
carry that gun
but were you asking for it
you were asking for it
the white kid with the rifle running
through the black lives matter [ __ ]
protest with a gun
you were asking for it that was
antagonizing
that was the hold on completely illegal
and in his rights
so who's wrong
this came out
of him his canada rifles white kid had a
rifle decided to go through the black
lives matter a point uh
protest apparently one of his friends
stores was getting
rioted on so he went down there like
you'll get the [ __ ] back which you
should cause it's your homie
but he started running through the
streets
and people start what i saw is he's
running through the streets with a
[ __ ] rifle and people are trying to
stop him and he shoots them because
they're trying to attack him
kind of sounds like self-defense but why
the [ __ ] do you got a gun
why do you shoot the guy in the chat he
couldn't shot him in the leg you
couldn't have shot in the air and like
get the [ __ ] back
also why is that man attacking you just
because you have a gun you have the
right to carry it
so it's like yo who's wrong do you have
a right to just yeah whatever
whatever state he was in had like legal
arms to brandish weapons or whatever so
he he was in his rights from what i'm
reading
i know a lot of people like you're a
piece of [ __ ] you're [ __ ] yeah i mean
there's actually one
written down and then there's reality of
what happens yes but he did fake cry in
trial which made me think like did you
you were just trying to shoot some
[ __ ] yeah yeah i get it i get
it i understand he's very pro mega kind
of thing so it's like
i feel like you did it just because you
need to get away with it because it's in
your rights but at the same time who are
you to be out here with a gun in the
middle of all these people protesting
it's stupid you're not a cop
so that's the same thing it's like it's
like yo
none of you are right none of you are
wrong the girls with the girls wearing
clothes like yo
why are you wearing a miniskirt at four
in the morning in the bad side of town
what's wrong with you
because you know how disgusting people
are
why do you have a gun in the middle of a
black lives matter right when they don't
want guns
what's wrong with you
both you have your right to do that
you're allowed to wear a miniskirt at
four why not well you should be safe but
remember people are [ __ ] disgusting
yeah same thing with that you have a
right to put yourself in a hyper
dangerous situation but that doesn't
make good it's like she was asking for
it is not real
it's
you should have thought first
what area am i going to because here and
i know a lot of people like she
shouldn't have to think are you ready
for me to shut you the [ __ ] down
ready this is the only time i'm ever
going to get slightly like politically
correct or whatever
the hole she was asking for thing that
whole kyle
brit house whatever shouldn't had a gun
but he legally showed him you shouldn't
attacked him
also why do you have a gun shooting
people i would attack the guy too like
yo he's going crazy let's just take him
down it's like an active shot it's
active shooter
you see a white kid running with a
pistol like with a rifle like yo let's
take his ass down before he kills all
these people i get what's going on let
me shut you all the [ __ ] up
and remember you're both right and
you're both wrong
there's a half and a half because it's
all about an opinion but half this
opinion is a law which is factual
you ready
if i'm a gang banger in merced which is
primarily norteno red you rock red and
14s
i have every right in my [ __ ] life to
wear a [ __ ] blue checkered shirt and
walk down 8th street
i have every right
but if i get [ __ ] shot in the back
what are they going to say
bro you were asking for it
shut the [ __ ] up whole debate is now
done
you know what kind of people are out
there
you shouldn't you should be cautious
you're gonna wear a kkk hat in the
middle of black lives right matter [ __ ]
no
are you gonna wear red and blue in the
middle of the [ __ ] red town you can
but get ready for the consequences you
might die
yo it's four in the morning you're going
to downtown l.a by yourself getting into
uber you're drunk
you maybe you shouldn't do that maybe
you shouldn't wear that maybe you should
go with somebody and have them get into
the uber with you and then make sure
you're safe
but you have every right to it's
different when you got a death machine
in your hand but do you see what i'm
saying it's like and none of these are
comparable i'm saying i'm comparing the
you're right and wrong you're right and
right now there is no right there's
nobody's completely right the gangbanger
thing makes so much sense and i hope it
made sense to you leave it in the
comments if it did because that's true
you know what i'm saying
you brought it on you're asking for it
that's when that makes sense the
clothing thing is true it's like where
were you going
i was in the nice part of town like oh
you weren't asking for it but you were
just living your life i was in skid row
at four in the morning
i was thinking that a lot when nipsey
got murdered like where is he he was in
front of his own [ __ ] it's your own
thing your own thing you wasn't asking
for it where you grew up i mean you're
you know you're in a hyper dangerous
area you're probably a target there's
always gang [ __ ] see what i'm saying you
know you're a girl you know you're by
yourself if you're in a pack of girls
bro good i don't i rosie can do whatever
the [ __ ] she wants as long as you're
safe
if i have to go outside and sit in a car
and make sure you're safe i'll make that
i will do that go do whatever you want
just make sure you're [ __ ] safe
because people are creeps people are
[ __ ] weirdos
always remember that so when people go
you were asking for it what they meant
their ignorant sense was
what they meant to say was
you know how disgusting people are right
you should be cautious that's what that
means
but when dad's like you were asking for
it he tried to [ __ ] molest you like
yo go kill that kid why are you telling
your daughter that you should never tell
your kid that because they're a kid
i'm saying but when these adults
let's get off the topic you keep what
i'm saying guys it's the only time i'm
ever gonna break [ __ ] down seriously
like that because it pisses me the [ __ ]
off looking at it she was asking for is
the wrong is super wrong at the same
time it's like where were you where were
you going what time you know what kind
of people are out there maybe you should
have hired security maybe you should
have had a dude or another girl come
with you another human
but anyway that kyle whatever he got off
killed four people no [ __ ] completely i
don't know how i don't know those bro
completely got off
four people he killed or three people
i don't know dude i don't follow enough
i only see memes bro i only see memes
enough to where i go i gotta see what's
going on and then i look into it because
i don't care enough like yo he killed
people happens a lot oh he's gonna get
off or you know or he's gonna go to jail
oh it doesn't affect me
but it's not like i don't care
he got off and now i care i i didn't
care when he goes to prison that's what
happened to go to prison
is he wrong is he right i don't [ __ ]
know he's in self-defense yeah why the
[ __ ] are you here
yeah it's like jumping in the middle of
a [ __ ] knife fight shooting people
like well you know well they had knives
like you put yourself in this situation
done no more of the topic
that's tough it is see what i'm saying i
remember when sickler was getting his
[ __ ] spot looted he was in that
predicament he was he lived that [ __ ]
they were up they had joe we had just
moved him in we literally filmed his new
studio though it would happen a couple
weeks ago too right no i mean i know
la's been [ __ ] interesting
their place got robbed again no [ __ ] i
didn't know that yeah like two three
weeks ago the [ __ ] santa monica music
center got [ __ ] looted again bro they
had to break in again he texts me
i text him about something goes yeah
sorry oh right before the episode right
before thanksgiving hmm yeah no i didn't
know that yeah they got [ __ ] looted
again jesus christ
stealing musical instruments what a
loser but he was in that scenario where
there was people out there with their
people across the street had the [ __ ]
aks out there people were looting people
weren't running up with guns and [ __ ] he
was trying to get his equipment out if
you're a store owner bro you got to
protect your [ __ ]
and if someone is still coming at your
[ __ ] with a gun down they deserve it
get the [ __ ] out of you like it's the
same thing as getting a strong arm
robbery they might just
people in rats go crazy
they're never gonna catch you if you did
beat you to death i'm not gonna know who
did that mm-hmm
so i get it i get the whole both sides
but no matter what it's still wrong
people got killed
we shouldn't be out there playing god no
thank you
let the cops do like yo
get that kid running with the rifle not
you run up with him try to take it and
get him or it was sad i saw the videos
it was really sad but uh
that's the only time i'll ever get on
that topic if you don't agree it's your
right to not agree if you do agree yeah
we're on the same level if you don't
give a [ __ ] you're me two weeks ago so
here we go guys next topic
fro all right here we go here we go
marty do me a big ol favor
wait where's your laptop
uh
i'll just
okay
you ready yeah last night i'm talking
about mushrooms
jay super smack bros and trent my friend
trent bring up
the correlation between santa claus and
mushrooms marty have you heard about
this
i have you have to i'm the one that put
you onto the show oh you're the one yeah
but they know you you were here oh we
were all here at the same time on the
phone huh
yeah you're on base time you thought i
was [ __ ] with you yeah i thought you
were [ __ ] with me but yeah no i
learned this [ __ ] from rogan back in the
day um that's what you did yeah about
how the whole like
explain
i don't know this [ __ ] good enough to
really sit here and [ __ ] explain it
but there the legend goes that the whole
the whole legend of santa claus and
christmas all came from the amanita
muscaria mushroom and the red and white
and how it looks and tripping balls and
seeing elves you can look it up how
christmas started as it relates to
[ __ ] amanita mysteria psychedelic
mushrooms christmas started while people
were like yo i was tripping balls this
guy in a red i ate the man in the red
suit and i started seeing elves
yeah christmas started it's because most
people put up these evergreens inside
their trees they came wrapped there was
[ __ ] mushrooms tending to grow at the
base of the trees
uh these red and white mushrooms i mean
we're going way back i don't [ __ ]
know but when you said you wanted to do
a christmas episode and we were talking
about doing a mushroom episode
scrambling for a goddamn you know theme
here
like that just kind of made sense i'm
like they are basically related i had no
idea so that's why i wanted to bring it
up like did you guys know this
i had no idea that christmas santa claus
meant mushrooms
drugs everything's about drugs i love it
yeah yeah rogan's got a whole yeah this
dude paul stamets that's who it was he's
like a super mushroom expert i've
watched him he's been on rogan at least
once or twice
and he talks about the wide variety of
[ __ ] different kinds of mushrooms
there are and [ __ ] and then yeah there's
a clip about it but it all i mean
this little children's holiday that we
have is a big bad [ __ ] illegal drug
that's awesome
one thing you need to watch i suggest
everyone out there go watch this tonight
i can't remember what it's on but it's
called fantastic fungi have you watched
it no
the most amazing [ __ ] i've ever seen
it's if it's a hundred percent mushrooms
89 of it is not about psychedelics
it's about how mushrooms the actual
fungi is will save the earth
they can clean up oil spills like that
yeah dude these are so spoiled like so
spores that they suck up the
water the oil in the water
they tried it and it would like
like a sponge it was [ __ ] incredible
bro and they cleaned themselves
watch mushrooms mushrooms go so deep
they connect to every [ __ ] thing on
the earth they go deep enough when they
grow
shocking i couldn't believe that
mushrooms communicate with each other
underground
it is [ __ ] weird phone call you've
never seen fergal you said i mean i've
seen it when i was [ __ ] five
ferngully everything is connected it's
just like fern gully go watch it
fantastic fungi it's not even in my
notes i just had to talk about it
fantastic fun guy is [ __ ]
amazing
so mushrooms and santa claus connected
let's go
wild
ready for my [ __ ] next topic
okay here we go
here we go i'm starting to feel these a
little okay slightly
kris kringle i feel a little oh that
you're saying crisp i do feel
i feel like my words
brisk brisk ice cream
you have to like my words bobbin here we
go
all right you guys ready
as you know we've talked about this for
months
i have a brand that was coming out
called the dopest thedopestshop.com
it dropped on friday
all right it dropped on friday sales
went live
the dopashop.com let me explain this to
you
i've always wanted a weed company but
then it's only the people in california
and you guys know that so far
it hasn't worked out for me yet i
haven't found the right partner yet so i
stopped
one thing
if you ever watch my dopa's yolo videos
the thing i hear more but more than you
should do story times yo you should do a
meet and greet the thing i hear more
than that times a hundred is i wish i
could smoke what you're smoking
god i wish i had something to smoke
number one thing number one thing when
i'm watching people's videos online i go
all right i'm gonna take a bomb damn why
did that make me want to smoke weed like
when i was younger you swatched
half-baked like oh god i want to smoke
some wii right now i don't know what it
is about seeing people smoke makes you
want to smoke
so i can only imagine all the people
watching our [ __ ] go oh my god god i
want to take a bong rip but they can't
because maybe they're in [ __ ] montana
or georgia and they're watching our [ __ ]
just wishing they could smoke or wishing
they could get high with us and hang out
so my friends and i made a brand it's
called the dopest it's made with hhc hhc
is another cannabinoid you know thc
delta 8 delta 9 delta 10 uh cbd so all
that stuff right this is called hhc hhc
is made from the hemp plant not the
psychoactive tac plant so let me explain
this to you you have a weed plant
weed comes off of it you smoke it
because it's psychoactive thc
psychoactive
still the same plant is this different
cannabinoid molecule so the hemp plant
produces
all the
hemp that you see people like cbds uh
non-psychoactive
joints damn are you opening up with your
teeth
goddamn bro oh my god you turned your
head like it was gonna break [ __ ] okay
so
we got the hemp plant and
extracted hhc out of it so instead of us
putting thc in our products we use hhc
why
thc gets you way higher [ __ ] yeah it's
from weed it's like from the thc
molecule hhc is the lower little cousin
that's not psychoactive so the
government just goes well it's not
psychoactive it doesn't get you high
it's no thc
yeah you can sell it yeah you can ship
it same as cbd to us
but in reality
but in reality
hhc gets you [ __ ]
up
that's what rosie was saying earlier
about the [ __ ] vapes yeah what i
don't understand somebody dm me this
morning goes yo i ate a thousand
milligrams didn't feel anything like
what
i 800 last night woke up today some
people have crazy tolerances that's just
this is what it is
but
the hhc that's in all of our products
will get you [ __ ] up all right but the
best part about it we can legally ship
it to your door any state any county any
city ship it straight to your door from
our factory
you can legally order vapes
and edibles
to your house
oh
so that's why we made this brand so
next time when i'm doing a story time
and i'm smoking something
you can be possibly smoking the same
thing i'm smoking or
you watch our videos now you can
actually eat some gummies get hang out
with us i just wanted to make everybody
included that's really what it's about
can everybody stay included and want to
hang out like
could you imagine watching our videos
forever and going man i haven't had i've
seen comments i haven't found weed in
months and that's [ __ ] sad i'd be
pissed
so
that's why we made the brand hhc it's
called the dopest thedopashop.com go
check it out you don't gotta reveal this
is there gonna be flower too
hash
flap everything you can think of
so excited i didn't know the answer to
that either yes yes we are
so basically guys we can ship it to your
door until the government uh makes it
illegal
you can order it all right the
dopashop.com
check it out guys so the reason i
brought it up is thank you so [ __ ]
much i had a number in my head that i
said if we can hit this in one day i'll
be so overly [ __ ] hyped
we quadrupled that number day one
it's now day
five
four it's day four or five
we're at times ten what i thought we get
damn yeah
no what time is eight we're times eight
the number of sales that we thought we
would have and our factory dude they
were shipping orders the day people
ordered them nice they're on it dude
they're [ __ ] they're not always
newbies yes they're thousands and
thousands of orders and they got them
all off so just wanted to bring it up
guys thank you so [ __ ] much for
making this drop successful i couldn't
believe it we've been deleted off
instagram three times this week the
dopest shop even though it's legal
instagram hates on me they deleted my
page three times in one week and all
legal products
so yeah
here's our other platform we can talk
about go check it out with dopashop.com
100 legal to your [ __ ] door
thank you guys for supporting
so excited
so [ __ ] stoked crazy
we you were watching she facetimed me
you're watching all the whole globe
light up with all the people on the site
yeah we can see like the globe and see
where everybody's ordering from zoom
into counties like oh this guy just
ordered oh it's for 70 bucks oh
oh oh
all over the globe it was so tight it's
only legal in us
but there's people in all countries just
logging on just trying and when i did
the google search it shows pretty simply
like even on just random sites like this
isn't things this isn't a substance
that's illegal in any of the states even
like the 13 states where
you know delta is it isn't necessarily i
was getting some comments and [ __ ] about
people being confused but like
man everything i search for online their
whole legal team like you don't i don't
think you have to worry about buying
this and then getting our lawyers update
us weekly yo this date just went legal
yo it's back legal again oh the the
senate just passed this our lawyers are
on it i don't have to do [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] excited this update me
so it's working so thank you guys so
[ __ ] much
appreciate it if you want to watch the
review go on the dopaziola channel it's
called i started an hhc brand
dope is the dopest shop.com check it out
thank you guys
on to my uh
on my next little topic
you're oh you can't see him
you can't see my nose yeah i'm sorry
on to my next topic
guys
we've been a an actual brand an actual
podcast for about eight months no 10
months
thank you for making all this possible
all right remember the first couple
episodes marty and i are like yo we just
want to get like a couple sponsors it'd
be really cool one day we're gonna start
hitting the big ones and all it finally
happened all right
it finally happened
marty do you want to say it no you got
this one sure yeah yeah please
all right
so shout out to brandon our ad agent
he's really crushing the [ __ ] out of it
this [ __ ] went out and got us
the deal of deals all right
so
happy to announce extremely psyched to
announce all 2022 marty me
dope as usual podcast are the official
2022 are you ready are you right
suspense
we are the official brand ambassadors of
2022 to miller lite
whoa
been working that [ __ ] for
whoa a long time a long time
wow doesn't quite feel real yet doesn't
yeah not until i get that [ __ ]
hopefully free agent
yep
let's go it's a big [ __ ] deal that
they locked in for the whole year though
that's what that's the evolution of like
the show yep they lost in the trial runs
to a full year with miller light
and what happened they saw other [ __ ]
went nano trial just just lock them in
like
ball
yeah
and it's that in and of itself is super
valuable and just being aligned with
them now just puts the world on notice
that this isn't some underground [ __ ]
yeah it's not just the weak kids anymore
like no miller light
paid us
miller light booked us for a [ __ ]
year
that's super valuable in and of itself
it's pretty cool yeah [ __ ] you guys no
miller high life me and my uncle john
it's in all the story times i used to
chug that [ __ ] that's that was
that mickey's grenades and mad dog 2020
but mostly miller highlight
because they're a dollar thirty two for
a 32 ounce [ __ ] glass bottle um uncle
john spent like 12 bucks get shit-faced
yeah it makes it more relevant even it's
crazy thinking about it like
because remember i've talked about on
story time me and john man one day
someone's gonna pass you smoke weed he's
like yeah someday someone's gonna pay me
smoke weed just try beer i go man maybe
one day and then we started getting paid
for the
for the weed [ __ ] and now it's like
i wish that [ __ ] was here man
that's the only thing it's like ah
i wish i could text your ass like yo
guess what guess what [ __ ]
you know because that was our beer and
when we said it one day and now it's
like wait one day it's a crazy
coincidence that it's that brand because
it was going to be a different brand it
was and then we locked in with miller
light instead
so how about his name's bran den
oh brand n
yeah brandon gets us in with brands all
right all right that's marty's
he thought that was so funny marty is
high as [ __ ]
stop marty's high as [ __ ] i'm a
wordsmith i'm sorry
oh yeah okay
so
miller light there it is guys
thank you very much
super excited soundboard
what are you about to press
oh my god
somebody said that you get you sparked a
ptsd with a gunshot oh sorry i get a lot
of comments about the [ __ ] soundboard
i never thought
it would be uh it'd be a thing oh yeah i
could see that
i can see that
um so thank you guys thank you guys so
much 2022 middle of life all
[ __ ] year
super sick thank you very much
um i want to do
the commercial i want to do like the
commercials from the 90s where
everyone's having a party on the roof
just because they have a can um
crack
yeah that's what i want dude it's gonna
be [ __ ] ridiculous it's gonna be fun
fun commercial i can't wait to do a
commercial just put me in the commercial
like put me in one commercial i turn
around hey
and then i'm like yo
stop it whenever you infuse beer let me
be the sponge person all right
so
here we go shout out to miller light
falcon shout out to john miller light
mill high live [ __ ] crazy years later
and we literally
got the contract
halfway through the premiere of the
dealing with death part two episode yep
that was a [ __ ] it was crazy
as we're talking about marty's mom
passed away
contract comes in
weird
and we had been waiting like four months
for that [ __ ] to like happen yeah
it's a trip man yeah i chose trippy all
right
uh the capsules officially just hit me
i can feel it the laser light's going
behind me or something no i could i just
felt this
nice like i'm on a slow moving boat
but not my
vision my brain
did this while you were talking yeah i
just got wavy
ha ha here we go
i start trailing and paint streaking i'd
be so happy yeah i'd be so excited if
all these things started dripping off
the walls
oh my god that sounds so fun
and i just want to be able to keep it
together so here we go um
you know what before we get into it i
think i think i'm gonna do this now
hey what's up guys just wanna say a
special shout out to one of our sponsors
this is my bookie so go to mybookie.com
anything you do the promo code is dope
as usual okay always remember that dope
as usual at mybookie.com right now
they're doing 12 straight days of
giveaways if you go sign up to be a
member of mybookie you automatically get
entered into the 12-day raffle so there
is no better time there's no better day
than right now to sign up with the code
dope as usual my bookie is matching all
first-time deposits so for everyone if
this is your first time they're going to
match your deposit all the way up to a
thousand dollars let me say that again
for all you gambling dudes out there
they will match your first deposit up to
a rack to get that all you gotta do is
use our code dope as usual right when
you sign up for my bookie i couldn't
tell you how many fights you're going on
right now the playoffs are about to
start this is betting season right now
all right it's christmas time this is
when everything's going on the super
bowl's coming up just log in sign up to
be my bookie 12 day giveaway guys up
matching your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars you're not going to
have better odds of anywhere than
mybookie.com you can bet anything
anytime anywhere my bookie remember code
dope as usual
all right youtube don't be getting
pissed off at us i'm not showing
anything but chocolate it may or may not
have four grams of mushrooms in it we'll
[ __ ] find out together let me make
sure actually
nothing but may or may not have four
grams of mushrooms in it here we go uh
since i have you know
the show to do still uh-huh i'm gonna
take a little bit a little little bit
with that protein bar
this protein vegan protein bar it's true
mushrooms have yeah that's what i'm
saying
i can smell them
things don't play it
tastes like mushrooms
it smells like stems
one gram two grams three grams four
grams
i'm just going to eat a big section
you have to drive you don't want to know
this right no i'm good yeah i'll be i'm
good i'll be one gram two grams three
and four grams so this is
yeah we're fine
slugworth
i don't know that reference
willy wonka okay
there's a whole [ __ ] stem in this
i can see it
come on bro drop it up better than that
i used to taste mushroom stems hmm
[ __ ] is raw no chocolate doesn't help
any super dark chocolate is vegan oh so
it's even worse yeah there's there's
some line where dark chocolate just
turns [ __ ] gross
bro there's chunks of stems in it
what do they normally do like grind them
up in the powder
supposed to be so simon [ __ ] like
tincture
hey remember that time i it just didn't
go back in the place
okay here we go
enjoy slow in a safe environment yeah
right
ate another grammish
so now what
two five about two five in oh wait
microphone sorry we're about 2.5 grams
and i felt those capsules that i knew i
knew it's time
nice
might as well just ate the [ __ ]
mushroom god
looks at my [ __ ] teeth
who puts pieces of chop who puts pieces
of stem in it
[ __ ]
imagine getting weed stems in your
edibles
totally had that before no shot let me
tell you a little story
let me tell you a little story
one time
paulo if you're out there
you remember this i was in my first
cannabis cup event first one ever san
francisco first one ever
i'm there standing in the circle
we're all chilling smoking just smoking
this super super nice like
if it was the 1400s he'd be like the
troll do with the long beard with an axe
like stubby
very small but like ah big dude not buff
like
damn that's a fat dude oh my god his
stomach's rock hard but he's fat those
guys
and uh
oh
i like catching are you starting to see
them
um
so
he comes up to us there's a circle of
like nine people
about yeah nine people like two chicks
the rest dudes
rosie's with me too
we're standing there this super nice
dude long red hair in a ponytail
comes up he's like yo he starts just
giving us a spiel but we're at the
cannabis cup there's no way he's going
to try to sell something to us you know
what i mean there's we're at a booth
there's no way this door-to-door booth
salesman
so i heard him out but in public
somebody so let me i'm like no get away
from me bro don't want to hear what you
got to sell don't care but everything
cannabis kept my yo what's up man i'm
plus i'm not mean i'm gonna say hey
hello
but the way he started talking like what
are you trying to sell
so
he starts talking to us the first thing
he talks about his mom has cancer and i
go oh [ __ ] okay what are you what are
you talking about
he's like yeah blah blah blah gets this
whole long spiel the whole long story
i'm not going to tell you the long story
it's pointless
he makes edibles for his mom should have
just started with that guy
he makes edibles for his mom goes i'm
going around the cannabis cup just
giving out free edibles to people i
wanted to try it see how they like it i
was thinking about making a company this
is before black market companies were
everywhere this is before that this is
2013
yeah 2013.
and we're like oh okay he already told
us about his mom he's super nice he
wants to give us edibles a try we're
like we all look at each other like all
right
he pulls out a plastic bag see-through
plastic bag this big of giant i mean i
don't where do you even get those gummy
worms
they're this big
gummy worms and i'm like yo i love gummy
worms let me get that [ __ ]
so he hands it to us he hands us all the
gummy worm marty
we start eating it and as i'm eating i'm
like oh
at first i taste sugar i'm like all
right [ __ ] gummy oh
i just taste hash oil like
you know when you take a dab a fat dab
and you almost get like a resin line on
your teeth like a stickiness and you're
like
damn it tastes like cash
not that there was actual like hash in
my teeth
i don't like that
i look at it and you know gummy worms
not the sugar not the sour worms so
there's no sugar on them the see-through
kind you know what i'm talking about so
you could see a light through the gummy
worm if you wanted i went like this
because he's still talking everybody
went like this
and it's like one two three four five
like five chunks of hash
shatter
in the gummy worm he didn't infuse
anything he just made his batch broke up
a slab and then started making sheets of
gummy worms
he didn't use anything he was like
rolling gummy worms he was rolling oil
into his gummies
as i'm doing this i look around at
everybody trying to be polite to the guy
that's standing in front of me trying to
be polite look over his shoulder and
he's not looking like
and everybody's looking at me too like
you know when something's really bad and
nobody just everybody stops chewing they
go like that
oh
you know everybody starts chewing
oh thanks man
you know what i'm saying like nobody
wants to spit it out
everyone's face everyone's face and i
i'm like oh no
did this guy just roofie all of us or
something like i don't i knew what was
going on but like all of us said yeah
strange man i'll eat it we're all we're
all being nice because he started off
with his mom talking about his mom
he walks away everybody
spits his [ __ ] on the ground all of us
put him right on top of a trash can
because it was a trash can uh
for cans like for bottles and cans
there's only a little opening mm-hmm i
didn't want to like mix it all in there
and feel like an [ __ ] [ __ ] up the
recycles
so i put it on the top and i felt worse
like yo if he walks by and sees a
a smidge bitten out of nine different
gummy he's gonna feel like an [ __ ] my
friend
one of our friends straight up did this
scrape her teeth
dabbed it huge huge dab like
glop
this man got us
he got us all
felt disgusting for an hour two hours i
didn't feel high just you guys know that
taste of
hash and you're not like uh hydrated you
just get
sticky dry oh my god tastes like
mushrooms
you get that sticky dry mouth that's
what i had just walking around the
cannabis cup aimlessly you can't get
drinks the line's 90 people long so i
just sat there
taste a little bit of sugar in the hash
random story why did we talk about that
because you found the stem
and you found the stem so yeah that's
the one time i talked to yeah [ __ ]
that was random okay here we go
it's always a [ __ ] victory when we
can figure out where we started from
that's true that's true
okay
all right
yo there's still two story times popping
up nice
last subject then i'll get off of it
oh yeah these mushrooms are yeah i
definitely feel it [ __ ] yeah nice here
we go
my whole family's are truck drivers you
guys know that every one of my dad's
side's a [ __ ] truck driver you my
grandma everyone
so i know a lot about trucks and all
about driving start driving i was
[ __ ] five with my dad on his lap when
i was like seven he started let me drive
by myself he'd sit next to me i've been
driving
so when i heard this story i'm like it's
a [ __ ] meme it's it's clickbait
there's no way it's real it's real
i don't know if you guys have heard
about this i just recent brought this up
to you
there's a there was a truck driver in
colorado that crashed killed four people
horrible super [ __ ] sad i'm sure he
feels like [ __ ]
this happens all the time people crash
and kill people called vehicular
manslaughter vehicular man slaughter not
vehicular i killed you on purpose
they gave him a hundred and ten years
there are people that get drunk behind
the wheel and kill kid and don't get
that long
there are people that shoot people don't
get that long you know what i mean like
what 110 years
so they're saying that he was super
negligent
uh could have been avoided every
accident could have been avoided
[ __ ] i don't know why colorado is
doing this to this one dude
but i told my dad my dad couldn't even
believe it because my dad's church i had
to get his opinion on it i when i talked
to him like what do you think about this
[ __ ] even he's like what the [ __ ] did
you say
because dude
he should got 20 something
max and yes i get it he killed four
people it's horrible i'm sure the
families of those people are like no
life give him life he killed my family i
get that but it was an accident man it
wasn't on purpose i get that the
families are pissed i understand that
but why is he targeted like this i don't
get it don't understand so there was a
huge protest i don't know if you saw it
marty all the truckers in colorado just
pulled over and stopped working
to appeal this full sentence
because it's not right it's not right he
[ __ ] gets 26.
damn wait he's 26 years old god damn i
thought he was like older truck driver
just started basically a couple years my
brother my little brother martin is a
truck driver he's [ __ ]
well 27
28 you know like that's like my little
brother crashing come to think of it
kind of looks like my little brother now
they're giving them 100 110 years
[ __ ] kill people and gangs you
get out faster than that so that really
upset the [ __ ] out of me i didn't
understand there's no way it's gonna
stick
that's impossible
that's not even real it's just it
doesn't make sense so i wanted to bring
it up i love that the fact that colorado
the truck driver is just like just
protesting like you want your [ __ ] no
all right then you go get your [ __ ]
class
a license or what is it class a yeah
class a because we have class c for
driving a car
yeah like let them go [ __ ] to truck
driving school for eight months no
you're gonna you're gonna appeal this
man sentence because it's not right it's
truly not right
he doesn't deserve that he's a [ __ ]
kid
but the only thing i'm like
so i kind of get why you guys are
throwing the book at him you know what a
runaway truck ramp is marty i only found
out about like i was like when we were
driving out here from buffalo in
colorado i couldn't figure out what they
were just the rocks yeah well it's like
a big ass yeah it's a ramp yeah for
everyone that doesn't know what i'm
talking about you're driving the freeway
and on the side of the freeway there's
like a ramp that goes into the sky and
gta yes and it's all made of rocks and
gravel that's so if the truck drivers
brakes give out like this guys did he
can pull off hit that gravel and your sp
i remember one time a guy went over it
when i was a kid because i've been in my
dad's truck my whole life and one guy
did go over it on the grapevine he went
too far he's going too fast he died that
was [ __ ] up but they built it longer i
remember when they were building the
next truck stop the truck ramps anyway
basically the truck driver oh my god i
can't stop pulls off the road while
going 80
hits that gravel ramp and they start to
sink because they're so heavy so it
stops your truck that's what's supposed
to happen but if you're going too fast
it's a ramp
but it's rather you die off the side of
the road then kill all the people in the
street or in the freeway i get it the
guy thought he could save it
she passed two runaway truck stops truck
ramps then hit the people that's why
they're like yo negligence but the same
time
negligence or not it was an accident
so that's why i wanted to bring it up
because my whole family's drug drivers
are me seeing this [ __ ] it's like wait
what did you just say that's my little
brother
this is essentially my little brother do
the same exact thing he's in the same
[ __ ]
same age same occupation it's not right
it's [ __ ] up
mushroom man
oh i gotta that's all i taste damn i got
that rick rock
[ __ ]
ugh did you see we i saw he went on a
podcast did you see that the fake rick
ross
regrossed the second rich ross a second
we should start calling that uh
he was on some random [ __ ] podcast
and then he decided he didn't want to be
on it anymore so he said he's gonna go
to the bathroom and he just got up and
[ __ ] left didn't come back maybe he
was [ __ ]
could be maybe all the wings stopped and
he was [ __ ] more horrific diarrhea
maybe he accidentally shut himself like
i'm out i'm gonna make it look like you
know i'm just hard on my left but really
what happened [ __ ] down my leg just [ __ ]
myself but i'll assume i'll assume i
feel comfortable assuming that's what
happened
maybe i don't think anybody just leave
an interview maybe just [ __ ] himself
nobody's that big of an [ __ ] but they
would just leave yo it's either you're
that big of an [ __ ] or you're [ __ ]
yourself that was the only two options
we're gonna assume you [ __ ] yourself
rick ross the second you know what sucks
is
once i hear about things people have
done it's like i can't i don't even want
to [ __ ] with you anymore because i would
love to have rick ross the rapper here
and talk about all the [ __ ] he's done
bro
after talking to the real red cross i
don't think i want you on here of course
i mean i'd like to talk to him about the
real rick ross that'd be [ __ ] amazing
you know what i'm saying like i wouldn't
think it's a great interview but at the
same time it's like
but rick ross the real one is tight and
you play with him would you just pay him
something yeah that's the only thing i
can talk about something you know
well i'm a [ __ ] c-class how did you
just defraud the world like this like i
don't know it's just not right you can't
be owning all this [ __ ] and go hey i
can't break you off
come on bro
come on you got to break them off that's
crazy i feel like some [ __ ] women
will sleep yeah like i can't i don't
know i can't let it go i can't not turn
that fool's [ __ ] [ __ ] off every time
it comes on
i'm like oh he's on the back end of some
of my [ __ ] favorite songs that's an
issue
i know what you mean
it's not like i hate him nothing like
that just like damn rick ross put it so
like this is what happened
soon as i realized that [ __ ] i was like
what the [ __ ] some [ __ ]
but
it is what it is it's fine as long as
you know if you don't have any morals or
values about yourself go ahead and
continue to [ __ ] be cool that yeah i
couldn't do that bro
i feel too played
for him
yeah
i can't do that um
here we go what's the time
oh
101 all right all right
he's ready for some [ __ ]
storytime
we gotta get bruce buffer
get ready for story time
and every time we tell a story you drop
that on the sound board
i don't know but he might copyright me
for that one i don't even want to
[ __ ] i can do it good
yeah he'll get you yeah i don't know i
don't know if i want to do that
yeah
yeah yeah
man he's a cool ass dude i'd love to
have bruce on here bruce is a [ __ ] g
he's seen so much
you know he's
the start of every raider game he opens
the raider game
i didn't i forgot to tell you that he
walked out on the top
las vegas raider he's the announcer guy
to open the show i forgot to say that
when i went to the show i went get the
[ __ ] out of here that's right he just
lives a couple minutes away
he lives in vegas like yeah that makes
sense it makes sense yeah
yeah he's had an interesting life he's a
cool ass dude for sure not to mention
being like his brother michael buffer
both of you guys just have cool voices
how about good hair you guys hearing
cool voices yeah
what a lane to pay for yourself and
you're brother
you're like jerry springer you're like
you're the first yeah and the only one
everybody remembers from trash tv or
announcing [ __ ]
bruce buffer now
it's two words
what bruce barber it's time i mean
that's like oh i was like
so random like
his brother there was one point they
were sitting there and like yeah you
know we're futures they both have louder
yeah what the [ __ ]
but you can pronounce his name better
than you
crazy
if you guys don't know his brother is
[ __ ] michael buffer the let's get
ready to rumble let's get ready he was
managing his brother and then he became
that dude for the ufc they're crazy
holy [ __ ] it's like the peyton manning
family or the damn yeah i guess this is
the peyton manning family
it's the manning family it's like damn
dude
eli manning yeah you're okay peyton
manning one of the greatest of all time
aren't you manning your dad well you
created one of the greatest of all time
you were okay
yeah i just one of their kids got to
step up now
three generations of [ __ ] nfl stars
bomb
for those who out there didn't know
archie manning is peyton manning and eli
manning's dad played for the saints
quarterback pretty sure he was a saints
either way baller
guys we rant hard
story time we gotta get him to do it
we got to get him to do it yeah so here
we go
this first story is from season three of
the dopest yellow story time
and yo
i don't want to be that guy just like
these are hitting me yet and eat more
i'm gonna give it to after the story and
maybe i'll eat more i could definitely
feel it right
here okay
and it's an odd piece
but i feel this
that's how i feel oh i just tasted now
oh i'm drinking blue gatorade so why
don't i taste down layers those are
mushrooms and chocolate all right
here we go
uh story time this is from season three
dobasiola are you [ __ ] ready
you haven't heard the story yet
i feel like you have
i really really really feel like you
have but you said you haven't heard of
my rich friend with the guns and all
that [ __ ]
paraphernalia
i mean it's possible but you know i just
i edited all the story times but i don't
let's no i'm saying on here mm-hmm oh no
yeah as long as you ever heard it tell
you this story that's all i care about
even though i went through all the
stories it's still so hard to find out
everything i've talked about
here we go guys
here we [ __ ] go here we go
what's up guys might be surprised to see
me i'm stepping in welcome to the
mid-roll ad read i'd like to give a big
shout out to one of our top sponsors of
the year manscaped now what is manscaped
you might be asking if you're sitting
here a new user manscaped is the male
hygiene
premium grooming kit that we use here on
the podcast of course we're only shaving
our pubes with the finest of equipment
and getting them smelling as nice as
possible for our ladies that you've been
meeting these past couple weeks here on
[ __ ]
anyway guys it's the new year it's a new
you
maybe you were a dirty nasty
[ __ ] last year 2022
you're coming for it
you're going to start with the
performance package 4.0 you got
space age technology going on for your
balls
you got waterproof ceramic blades on the
lawnmower 4.0 you're trimming in the
shower your girl's already impressed you
got the clone for the balls the ball
toner you got the ball wipes going your
levels above the competition they got
the [ __ ]
they got the nail trimmer going they got
the mat for your pubes when you're
trimming they got the boxers going they
got the shed going landscape.com codiola
get 20 off plus free shipping
all the products that you could ever
need ladies if you don't if you want to
send a nice message to your man that
needs to step his [ __ ] up manscape.com
slash yola 20 off plus free shipping new
year new you fresh balls
what's up guys
you're looking into the [ __ ] third
eye there boy welcome to the mid-roll ad
read we'd like to thank one of our
sponsors our main sponsors for the year
on it
yeah heavy duty on the shroom tech over
here at dope as usual with the on it
like we're talking about here on this ad
break new year coming up it's a new you
this is legit i've been rocking with on
it since the dawn of time since i
started first listening to jre back when
this company was invented the fact that
they sponsor our podcast now is amazing
top of the line earth grown nutri
nutrients across the board we got the
vegan products we got the non-vegan
products
now they're starting to take the
flagship products and make them a little
bit more convenient with the alpha brain
with the shroom tech with the new mood
they got the on-the-go powders going
where you just pop them in with your
drink bam your cognitive function your
immunity your overall
self is just enhanced and optimized i'm
not vegan i got the protein powder going
and my shakes we got the coconut oil
going we got the new mood going we got
the melatonin going thomas is sleeping
on it.com
yola that's 10 off everything in the
shop except for the weights so we're
talking about the gear we're talking
about the supplements they update the
site all the time they do giveaways they
give away free information they give
away workouts they got a bunch of elite
athletes featured on there don't get me
started on the social media team the
social media content coming out on it is
amazing and it always has been on it.com
yola 10 off
everything across the board except the
weights
get on it
i have a friend named dylan you guys
have heard about him before he is the
kid indian kid with long hair
he's not indian he's like white i mean
native american
he looks like a native american kid
straight up long ass hair wide cheeks
but his [ __ ] mom's mexican and his
dad's white and i'm like yo
weird you're not looking like a mixed
white mexican anyway
if you've heard this before
uh he's a gamer katie comes over to
ryan's where he always get [ __ ] up
finally go to dylan's house
i didn't know
that dylan was ballin
very wealthy did not know this
no idea he's a death metal kid plays
games always wears cool shoes
death metal kid cool shoes doesn't
really mix it's like what
sneaker head death metal very odd mix
go to his house as you pull my
did your mom work for this family or
something what's going on here oh it's
your house
oh this is your house
oh oh
that's the back out you have a backpack
it's like fresh prince
you have a pool house [ __ ]
so we go to buhack uh which is outside
of merced and that's the ball in the
houses
so we get out there
and uh we got a bunch of mushrooms all
right
we got a bunch of mushrooms so this is
what's this is what this night's gonna
be i got cocaine i got mushrooms
i had met dylan's dad briefly
one time
and this is the first time i'm actually
talking to him chilling he doesn't know
who my stepdad is my stepped as a white
supremacist is probably
higher ranking than this [ __ ]
when they go to prison
you know what i'm trying to say he's not
going to be like who's your who's your
[ __ ] stepdad
there's no way the reason i bring this
up is he was a straight up hell's angel
style dude
ballin
dangerous mix too much money and
affiliated
he had a construction company merced
very well known so they were balling
well-respected construction company
low-key affiliated money
nope i already knew what this man was
about the second i saw him cause i seen
my step-dad's home he said he's gonna be
one of them
i meet him and i go okay guy was six
seven almost six eight a massive man
like he's a and i always ask dylan why
is your dad so big and you're nice like
my mom's short like that makes sense his
mom's a small mexican lady so all right
about six seven real real real big dude
though like 350 but not a super fat just
he's huge
uh
leather like the caps that the bikers
wear you know the [ __ ] leather jacket
on what the [ __ ] his is i won't say what
gang but he had his motorcycle jacket on
but the thing i noticed
i i told you about this truck before i
don't ever told you about this truck
he had like a lift did you guys ever see
like over f250s and they get like 350
450 like yo where where'd you buy this i
never even see this on the car a lot
you know i mean when they get into
monster trucks he had one of those like
the lifted ones where you see somebody
go they must own a concrete company
because that's a 300 000 truck
one of those trucks decked out silver
chrome air horns on it bomb
nobody else noticed this i had noticed
it right away
because my step-dad i saw it
went what
where merced
this fool had the ss bolts etched into
his gas cap
you know what i'm talking about
the white supremacy ss bolts the hitler
youth ss
boom
uh my step dad had him tatted all over
him
bam on hit on the outside of his car
the confidence and [ __ ] level of i
don't give a [ __ ] you have to have
for for you to rock that in a mexican
town is absurd
you don't give a [ __ ] about nobody at
that point and it's a
bomb ass truck like a bomb
more expensive than most people's houses
truck cops gonna look at him go dance a
nice truck i wonder what he does ss
bolts oh [ __ ] i ain't getting involved
with this and they keep going
other gang fools that see it go
he's riding around like that i'm
probably not going to approach him then
they see him come out the store six
eight like
i didn't see [ __ ]
i didn't see nothing you know i'd be
like oh super sport that's a super sport
right ss yeah all right good truck nice
truck that's pretty much what's gonna
happen he's a big he's a big man like a
very big man
long ass hair
like he's just one of those dudes you
guys know exactly who i'm describing the
big dude wearing leather [ __ ] jacket
just
too big
anyway huge beard
i'm only describing the truck we're not
even in the house
i see the truck almost like yo dylan
what the [ __ ]
there's other people like me
your dad my stepdad's a piece of [ __ ]
white supremacist you're mexican mom
over here you're stuck in the middle
all right except you grew up with money
sick
like you're just like me you have to
deal with this ignorant [ __ ] and
then later on i went oh oh
so we go in the house
eat mushrooms all right eat all the
mushrooms we're smoking joints i got
about
to myself 25 with the coke but in
reality it's like 150 bucks we all have
it on one sack so we're all like
don't be going to the bathroom by
yourself [ __ ] i know
we're all doing coke together don't try
to sneak up you know it's one of those
like where you going huh
leave that sack right there no bathroom
trips [ __ ] you so we all take our
mushrooms we're all chilling we're
hanging out i mean his dad see the truck
whatever
so
we're hanging out
dylan where the garage dylan goes you
want to see the guns and my dad i don't
know he says you want to see uh my dad's
guns he looks at his dad by the way
his dad
[ __ ] our whole coke night up we were
chopping rails in the garage dad didn't
give a [ __ ] he had this thing that had
two straw is a metal piece of metal look
at the letter y uppercase letter y
two pieces of metal that go into your
nostril and they go into one tube so you
grab it
you put the two things up your nostril
and you hit the rail and it goes on both
nostrils he had that [ __ ] in his pocket
he does cocaine all right this is a rich
man's drug and he's definitely rich
he had in his pocket we chopped up a lot
of what to us it was a lot
that was like six of our lines
this full
the whole thing in one and i remember
looking over his shoulder not over
shoulder like this
around this man that dylan like
the [ __ ] bro
your dad just did like a whole gram
we got four rounds [ __ ]
i just remember feeling like playing
like man
nice house i guess [ __ ] they can let me
stay here but [ __ ] i was just pissed
like you just did
four hours of fun [ __ ] you anyway
does anyone see my dad's guns after he
does that rail i'm like yeah i guess i
want to see his [ __ ] guns
and he goes
dad can we show him the room and i heard
oh sorry he's got the waves going on
this room is [ __ ] wavy oh
[ __ ]
the walls just started breathing on me
let's get through this story
oh what oh god here we go
okay here we go
uh
there you go
and he goes
can you show them the room and i hear
room go oh my god there's a room for the
guns damn
walk into this room and uh you know how
teenage girls not all teenage girls you
know teenage girls just a lot of clothes
on the floor like the typical one you
walk clean up this room on movies one of
those like stuff everywhere but it was
all guns and ammo
the way people have clothes on the floor
is boxes of ammo i walked in saw skunks
scattered everywhere i'm like oh okay
i've seen guns before i'm like oh okay
there's a lot of guns
his dad gives us a tour it's a room this
size marty maybe
cut off the table back and it's the rest
of the room not a huge room but
if it's full of guns it's a lot of it's
a lot of stuff
walk in there's a bunch of gun safes
like four gun safes against the wall but
it's just a [ __ ] mess it's a mess
there's cardboard boxes there's metal
boxes with a like a handle on top that
have like ammo box i don't know much
about guns but i'm assuming it's ammo
boxes
boxes everywhere green ones black ones
with yellow writing on it a lot of
military print
a lot of boxes had a military stamp so
i'm like yo whistle is affiliated
and um
he starts showing us the guns and this
is where i went
dylan this is what you [ __ ] deal with
every day what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] opens up one gun safe
and call of duty started
um you know call of duty they have a
the super long like ak rifles that are
camouflaged
he had that he pulled it out and looking
at it like i don't want to hold it no
his dad doesn't know i ate a bunch of
mushrooms he doesn't care
but his dad doesn't know i'm on i'm i'm
about they're about to hit me i ate them
an hour and a half like i'm waiting for
the mushrooms like you wanna see the
room
yeah i guess so i'm waiting for these to
hit me that's what we were at or maybe
the coke didn't help but anyway
we're standing there he's showing me the
guns and then he pulls out this sniper
rifle i don't know if you guys have ever
seen you know the op make a custom class
on call of duty
he could have done this it was a long
sniper rifle with all of these leaves
attached to it like fake
bushes marty
like like the green netting
like uh
like fishing net on it
hanging off of it like over it with all
these fake leaves in it
so when you just put it on the ground
that [ __ ] disappears like it's just in
the ground of leaves and bushes and [ __ ]
but i'm holding it and i'm holding like
this like whoa
this is a sniper rifle what the [ __ ]
i've only and this is this is so long
ago bro
i'm 15 at the time so this is a long
time ago and i'm looking at like wow
this is kind of scary and i put it down
and i'm looking at the guns and dylan's
looking at me side eye like
oh [ __ ] oh my god yeah he's like he's
excited he loves this stuff and he's
showing me ryan and one other person so
we're all like whoa
what the [ __ ] you guys remember men in
black
remember when uh
the alien that put edgar he puts on the
skin suit
and he starts walking around taking [ __ ]
remember and then he tries to put uh
he goes and kills the dude and tries to
take the
orion's belt
and then he goes out and his truck's
getting toes like
and these trucks getting towed and he
brings out the shotgun it's saw stop and
the truck driver goes please remember he
pulls out the gun and you never see the
end of the barrel
plea
that gun this [ __ ] pulled that
out the safe it was like a revolver but
the barrel
it was like a cartoon the barrel was
like a [ __ ] two feet three feet long
like you would have to hold it like this
it was a novelty
he pulled it out and thought of whoa
made him black gun
all right that's cool
he's going through show me rifles all
this crazy [ __ ] then he shows me this
one long machine gun and it's got a
a big piece of like metal tube not a
tube like a metal bracket on top and
it's stuck halfway up
so here's the gun but there's a bracket
that lays down but it's stuck like this
it's a [ __ ] rock a grenade chucker
like the launcher
and he's like yeah man i [ __ ] bought
this thing i shot one [ __ ] grenade
never worked again i can't get it to go
down i can't get it to lay down if you
can figure it out thank you and he's
telling me this i'm like
you shot a grenade off of this
oh my god and i'm looking at like oh my
god that is where a grenade goes and i'm
looking at like wow
i don't know if i [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
this is kind of scary right she opens up
another safe and he has the two uzis
from uh san andreas the oozies you see
in movies two of them like twins
revolvers desert eagles whatever
whatever and then
you guys are ready
mask reference but my tummy gotten down
you know oh wait that was the
home alone but when he's doing the
[ __ ] when he's doing the balloon
animals a tommy gun
remember the tommy guns from all the
mafia movies the black ones they got the
big barrel
drum
this [ __ ] smiles goes you ready
turns around
with a tommy gun like with a handle
the grip with the pistol the big drum
thing in the middle
like a [ __ ]
valentine's day massacre mafia
tommy gun
i'm holding it
i'm looking at it
and i'm like yo
this is [ __ ] insane and then right
when i say insane
the mushrooms smack me right in the face
they finally kick in i go
i get like the waves
and i go
i'm good i'm done and my friend dylan's
like you don't want to like look at it
go
oh no i'm good his dad's like you all
right
i'm a mushrooms man they all just hit me
i don't want to wear i don't want to
even be around these guns i'm actually
going to get out of the room and he goes
oh
this big [ __ ]
get out of here and just laughed it off
and i went back into the garage like i
went in there like three of my other
friends are doing the same [ __ ] like oh
that just hit me too like yeah i know
i was holding the tommy gun like tommy
and they all went in like what i haven't
seen the time they already know about
the guns they already knew dylan was
rich i just didn't know
so i found out dylan was rich dylan's
dad has ss bolts on his truck he does
massive amounts of cocaine while
breathing
and um his guns are just
out of this world it's just scary
night's not over this is [ __ ] an hour
and a half in it's friday night it's
barely 8 30.
we're up until seven like we're getting
[ __ ] up we're in high school we got
the
dylan has his own we're in the garage
right and dill goes let's go to my room
dylan's room is a house he has a pool
house there's a two-bedroom house with a
kitchen
a kitchen two bathrooms two rooms a
living room all decked out and that was
his room that he chills with his friends
in but he sleeps in the main house my
homie was bawling i had no idea so
night goes on
i'm all juiced up i'm tripping i'm
[ __ ]
but his dad's cool everybody's drinking
beer at the fire pit so we're not in
dylan's back house yet so we're kind of
just hanging out in the garage going in
and out his mom's making food and [ __ ]
she shouldn't have been enabling all
these kids on monsters doing coke with
the dad
with guns
yeah rich
rich
ball and marty balling
so
i'm tripping i every time i'm on
mushrooms i feel like if i'm smoking a
cigarette i went back now smoking or
joints now i touch the joint and it's
like it's does it's like it's paper i
know it's paper but it's like paper thin
it's like it's not there like i can just
roll it and it will dissolve that's how
i always feel about them
so i'm sitting here just
outside of dylan's and i have to go the
bathroom gotta go to the bathroom go in
the main house go to the bathroom
their whole bathroom is a
ship vacation theme
boats nettings
fake boats uh dude surfing a picture you
know like
under oh guys mushrooms just hit me
underwater vibes right so i get in there
just
chipping like whoa it's all underwater i
swear i heard seagulls and
i heard all the [ __ ]
so
i walk in i'm looking at myself in the
mirror for an hour like whoa
i gotta go to the bathroom i don't have
you ever tried to take a [ __ ] on
mushrooms not fun
so i go sit down and the toilet is 80
miles away as i'm sitting down it's
going further away like what the walk
just sit
go to the bathroom i'm not sure if i
wipe my ass right because i am [ __ ] up
and i'm like dude don't walk out there
there's like [ __ ] all over your arms or
something
ah so i don't know how long i was in
there it was an ordeal
as i get up
i look up i'm like
whoa ceiling fan looks crazy
i'm in a bathroom
it's not a house party it's all dudes
we're all just smoking and hanging out
it's a lot i'm 90 white dudes
it's not like we're all like dancing and
[ __ ] playing music we're all just
chilling in the garage with sweaters
smoking doing what [ __ ] white dudes
do in the [ __ ] in the winter and
we're all in mushrooms doing coke
you're probably doing that right [ __ ]
now right
all right i get it and we're drinking
keystone lights all right sorry my life
we're drinking he's still nice because
it was cheaper
all right
i lay just lay down in the bathroom guys
in the middle of everybody just chilling
i lay down in the bathroom and i just
start staring the ceiling fan the floor
was cold but there was like a
a rug so i felt like
weird i just stared the ceiling fan for
i couldn't tell you how long
feeling exactly how i feel right now
actually which is so odd to me i feel
very
that's how i feel right now marty they
definitely
i like those caps
i feel like the walls are doing this
but just the tops are coming in on me
[Music]
you know what i'm saying they're not
i know they're not marty
that's what i'm here for yeah
and uh
uh oh so i'm laying on the bathroom
floor
everything looks so much cooler i love
it
so vivid
um
i'm laying on the bathroom floor i
couldn't tell you how long i was there
but i remember the ceiling fan spinning
and for a couple seconds it just
detaches and starts spinning into a
globe and i'm watching this globe just
spin
i don't know what brought me back but i
just went get up go back to the party
there's people here i just sprung up out
of nowhere in the middle of this fun i
was having go out
there's like six extra people i haven't
that are there now i don't know how long
i was in the bathroom hmm
undetermined amount of time no idea also
nobody had to go to the bathroom in this
time oh dudes probably just out there
taking piss in the yard get it
nobody wondered where i was
you guys are out you guys are also
mushrooms too but not everybody was
so i go out there we're all getting
[ __ ] up doing rails i'm like yo
well call so and so my asian homie the
gangbanger full he sells uh ecstasy like
hey
why don't we call bleep why don't we
call so-and-so
i'm gonna come out here and like sell
some pills
joe me and joe run some pills i'm like
sell us pills
we'll have him drive out here we were
like yo he's not gonna come out here and
drive off to drop pills
what if he was like yo come chill smoke
oh it brings some pills i think people
want some [ __ ] that's how i got him out
there
slight very i felt like a dick afterward
but that's how i got him out there so we
call him
i don't know how much time has gone by
guys i have no idea i completely forget
i call them
so
dillon's in the pew hack so it's in the
country
really nice houses there's only houses
on one side of the road in the country
all right it's not on both sides it's
like one side of the road
so the other side i'm walking the
opposite side of the houses
so i'm just walking like the dirt just
small i remember i was smoking a
cigarette or is it blunt i can't
remember
i think it was a blunt you know what
it was a blood i'm smoking a swisher
and i'm getting down to like just like
the hot yeah it's like this much left
i'm smoking it
and i know when i'm really gonna start
peeking hard
when uh my knees start to buckle my
knees start to feel like really like uh
unstable
like my knees feel like they're gonna
get that
uh limbs falling asleep when i get that
my knees i'm like
oh i'm about to peek i don't know why
mushrooms have a physical reaction in my
knees so i knew it like
it's coming so i'm standing there it's
just the most peaceful thing in the
world
smoking of blood
looking up at the stars in the country
so i see all the stars like i'm in the
cuts
i'm looking up i'm 20 yards away from
the house like i'm across the street but
like i'm i'm going up and down the
street just walking just a high-ass kid
with long hair just oh that's what you
saw if you passed me right
no cars came by as i remember
and i'm super observant so i know when a
car is popping up man i know for
[ __ ] waiting for everyone
around the corner
i'm observant so you can't sneak up on
me
i'm standing there just smoking my blood
just staring at the sky thinking like
this is [ __ ] perfect
and then out of nowhere i just hear
thomas and i almost [ __ ] my pants
i i jumped up like when you scare cats
and movies and videos that's how i
jumped
i jumped
and it's my [ __ ] drug dealer friend i
go
what are you doing out here
like yo i'm in the middle of the country
why are you here he goes
bro you called me
and that's what it all came back like
that's right that's right pull over
right there see everybody's cars
park right there i'm gonna smoke this
i'll be right in uh joe and everybody's
inside go see ryan
i forgot that i called for ecstasy
yeah
so he goes in the party i'm just
finishing my blunt
i walk in
i take the pills
i don't remember much
else there's more to the story but as
far as mushrooms goes
i just remember it being you know that
cold garage
everybody's just smoking at the end of
the night all the drugs are gone
it's a depressing feeling damn how do
you even feel the the ecstasy when you
got coke going you got mushrooms growing
you got weed going you got alcohol
growing streams are stronger yeah i'm
saying
you pop the [ __ ] molly or whatever
and shrooms are stronger you don't even
feel it yeah i don't even remember if i
took that actually
remember i bought it
yeah and that was uh going to dylan's
house on mushrooms that's how that whole
night just played out we went there so
much that's where spencer almost died i
told you my friend spencer almost died
about his appendix i tell you that story
i don't know
maybe at a later date i'll tell you that
story same house except we were in the
pool house same
yeah that's what happened did anything
ever happen with this dude's dad he had
er
oh they got divorced
and then that's it that's all i've ever
heard
no no he um he had to unlock he's got
he's wealthy
had the business
i know if i would just send my stepdad's
name he would have been a different
conversation like
why do you know that name is that's my
dad
then it would be like a whole different
ballgame but i don't there's no need for
me to be like by the way we know
somebody what the [ __ ] the point i'm
just a brown kid in your garage bro
don't need to know more than that
no thanks
but um yeah that's how that that night
ended well i mean more [ __ ] happened but
nothing to do with with shrooms he's got
[ __ ] up
but yeah
that's what happened and oh not done
thing that made me like oh remember
earlier i went
oh damn
this is what got me like that right
right after the mushroom started kicking
in
my friend comes in with me like hey
check this out just like in american
beauty
check this out remember he goes and gets
the plates and nazi plates he brings me
a nazi ruger
a ruger gun or luger whatever you call
it the pistol
with like the serial number
like the swash stick is in it
all the [ __ ]
1940s evil
memories
that guns probably killed so many
[ __ ] people but he was like
juiced
to show me he's like yo check this out i
looked at him like
i'm not the one bro i don't think that's
cool i think i could tell he's like oh
well i don't think it looks cool i just
it's paraphernalia like it's history i
go yeah i don't know
but uh
i find that he has a whole shelf
of paraphernalia there was plates
other guns but i remember looking at it
swash to cut in the gun i just went evil
get it away but yeah that's how that
night ended
and it was fun
marty where are we at
god damn man 1 30.
josh wolf i might give it up to you man
you do this all the time keep it the
[ __ ] together pretty good together
pretty [ __ ] well because right now my
head just wants to do this
like fall back i just keep feeling like
a pull like someone's pulling me
okay
sorry
uh
oh oh yeah yeah they definitely work
yeah they definitely work
oh
dude the headphones are not a good thing
with mushrooms man yeah they're not fun
bro i keep thinking real sensitive with
the [ __ ] soundboard
it's just
i just hit manual breathing anybody else
do that
that's what i was just happening i do
that all the time april's like what the
[ __ ] is the matter with you just having
a breath sorry not like that i'm doing
it because i my brain told me you you'll
breathe
my [ __ ] inner conscious didn't go
dude we do this we do this every day
my brain just said nah we're going to
leave that to you do it by yourself
today
so that's why oh my god these walls bro
about all these walls any still image i
looked at while i was tripping balls
immediately became an animated
like
oh
all right i like the capsules
but was it the capsule of the chocolate
bar nothing happened to you ate that bar
but it was a combination that's how it
was a combination yeah
how about tripping but i noticed like oh
you ever be in your house you sitting on
the corner of your eye you have to stare
at the room like
i know i saw some oh it's my hair okay
never mind that's how i feel
like do you guys know my passwords
these walls know my passwords to
everything
um we're at 1 30
uh what time is it in regular day life
like three like 5 30. oh
oh we started at three yeah
okay
here we are
so this is coming out what two days
after christmas
we're about to go up to big bear
yep
i've just been in a [ __ ] fog i still
got a good [ __ ] for christmas
oh yeah i barely did that i barely did
two days ago so don't feel
you have more [ __ ] on your plate but uh
oh
sorry i'm trying to keep it together
here and i can feel like my thoughts
being
lagging did you have more notes i got
one more note is this so odd it's like
the last rep on your
hair
that's how i feel like your last note
i'm trying to get there it's not like
this is bad it's just
you know when your brain is just done
like i'm over it that's how my brain
feels get up why are you still sitting
here that's how i feel like yo get up
bro
go outside or something
uh yeah i'm not tripping but i can
definitely feel my body starting to feel
the tingles like right now my legs ugh
uh
here it comes
i don't got no editing to do
i'm just gonna go home be a useless
unproductive person that sounds great so
amazing i'll say it sounds kind of cool
but not like this
all right here we go last note
uh
yeah
things are smacking oh yeah those are
working
yeah those are working i've never done
drugs like this well josh wolf with
those those microdoses barely hit me
these ones are
three times as strong i can feel it
already
it wasn't yeah it must have been it must
have been the pills because it must have
been the pills because you only took
like
one of the little blocks right
i took like three oh okay
ah okay let's get into this topic oh i
could
yeah i'm not tripping i'm not gonna trip
out and see [ __ ]
i'm starting to get the
it's hard to keep uh focus
here we go let's end it christmas it's
christmas time
[ __ ] saint nick's kicking in boy
that was fast
the chocolate bar hitting quick then
yeah it was like that was really quick
fast really quick actually
[Music]
yeah i could feel my whole body starting
to just kill tinkles
oh [ __ ] okay
oh god last note
what are you thinking about right now
laying in a beanbag chair
i thought of my whole body going
on a beanbag chair thinking how big of a
being that all this happened right now
a pretty big being back here how much do
you think would be would i have to put
it together all of that just went
thinking
in that one moment i'll be back here be
sick like the blob and heavyweights but
it beans exactly but a beanbag chair
yeah i'm getting all the tingles on my
body all right here we go
christmas
this came out right after christmas
let me tell you guys a really good story
let me tell you guys about christmas
time all right let me wake the [ __ ] up
let me drink this water
ralph hey randy
ralphie
she's such a cool mom
here we go
she got canceled for that soap and the
mouth technique though she had cancelled
she would have oh yeah
soap in the mouth doesn't work just
punch your kid in the face
definitely i'll take a soap in the mouth
after that soap in the mouth was the
alternative
i just opened the mouth once i was a kid
really damn that's some old school [ __ ]
it was because of the movie i think my
mom was like yeah see see inspired by
the movie yeah i think so
i soap with the mouth one time
it wasn't that bad it gives a [ __ ]
if you kind of get it scraped on your
teeth it stays yeah or it's that harsh
device yeah like the hatch here we go
so the first
six years of my last seven years of my
life i had the violent flu
during christmas
never failed
every year people are all around the
tree every [ __ ] year i am spinning
got the flu
you know you get the flu where you
hallucinate
that was me every year every [ __ ]
year
until i was like six or seven whoa i
have been staring at cameras my whole
career
never once have i actually seen it look
like a person's eyeball
it's the same [ __ ] thing with the
lens
it's a person's eyeball but i've never
actually looked in it like that
zoomed in yeah i'm like zoomed in on it
and i can really see that looks like a
person's [ __ ] eyeball
creepy here we go
so i had the really bad flute yeah in a
creepy way yeah in a creepy way i'm over
here thinking like hey man the eye is
amazing you really think about it it is
like a lens in a creepy way
like somebody's watching yeah yeah for
sure uh
so
i'm always at my grandma at dolores
house cause that's where i was who
raised me basically when i was a kid
and i was always on the little couch
that's right to the left of the of the
well if you look at the front door it's
right behind you
every year never fails i'm sitting there
hallucinating getting the shakes because
i'm so sick take me to the hospital
jesus christ you got the [ __ ] red
fever or something i had i had a every
year for six years dude just sick sick
and uh throwing up
getting the shakes hallucinating i
remember one year i saw
this bear's face and then a witch's face
i just watched blizzard a bear's face in
a witch's face like in a circle like ah
oh
and they're all in a circle and i was
sitting there like is this real is this
real are they really here and i was
losing my [ __ ] i was like four when this
happened i remember
i was throwing up and throwing up sprite
and crackers spriting crackers it's all
i was eating i remember all that [ __ ]
anyway
this is every year my grandma's nursing
my ass every [ __ ] year never fails i
hated christmas
and then
one year i don't know if i hallucinated
it i'm pretty sure
my grandma and grandpa both took this
one to the grave
i don't think i hallucinated it
but one year i remember i'm like this
trying to open my eyes you know i'm i'm
covered up as a kid just sick on the
couch
tv's over here so i'm like looking at it
and the door's over there and i see
santa claus
i know i'm sick
but i also see santa claus in the
[ __ ] house
but santa claus stumbling into the house
like a
shoulder oh hits the door and then they
open it kind of stumbled into the house
like
drunk as [ __ ] santa
i see this guy santa claus and i'm like
no way is it because i'm sick and he
doesn't think i'm here under the blanket
is that why he's here i was like oh my
god i'm here santa claus is here oh my
[ __ ] god i'm just sick with the
blanket right here like no
way
and then he opens the door
just like oh you see him like slamming
into the [ __ ] walls like whoa santa
claus where's your bag at [ __ ]
that's what i'm thinking and then my
grandma i see my grandma come up and
just start slapping the santa claus
slapping him get the [ __ ] out he's
asleep get out of here get out of here
just slapping santa claus i'm like
is this
happening is this real
what is going on
i saw my grandma dolores hitting this
santa claus smack him smacking him
smacking him
pushed him out the door he's arguing
with her she locks the door the screen
the gate and then close the door and
locks it
and that's all i remember
i wake up in the morning
i asked my grandma grandma
and i tell her the whole thing she's
like
you know i'm a kid she's like uh
no
no no santa claus is not coming here and
i i beat his ass and made him leave you
know she's basically giving me the whole
you're you're sick you're hallucinating
i come to find out
years later before the three strikes
you're out or before the law california
law
my grandpa had like nine duis
never knew that
turns out my grandpa used to like to
drink and drive
was that my grandma coming back from a
[ __ ] holiday party and my grandma
beating his ass to get out
because i've heard of her locking him
out of the house once or twice before
when he's too shit-faced
was that my grandpa coming home from the
holiday party
he's asleep get the [ __ ] out that's what
i heard he's asleep i heard her saying
that she's talking about me okay but my
boys don't matter grandma santa claus no
no give me give me a give it
was it her talking [ __ ] to my grandpa
because he wasn't there in the morning
or was i really sick
or was it actually [ __ ] santa claus
it definitely wasn't saying maybe it
wasn't santa claus not going to sixth
street
to give [ __ ]
nintendo's no
so that's all i think if you were gonna
have a santa claus trip it would have
been a little less realistic than that
you'd have been doing some magical [ __ ]
that's all i saw
that's what i'm saying that's why it was
reality i think it i think it was my
grandpa and i think he was coming back
from like the company party [ __ ] up
yeah it was probably easier to explain
than yep so you're jose you're sick but
i asked her years later and she denied
it
so was it my grandpa hallucination
or santa claus
i'd leave it in the comments guys yeah
you're in the comments and on that note
bro i am i'm i'm almost at the point of
like
[ __ ] guys
i can see little shapes coming out of
stuff not see it but
i probably shouldn't do the ads first
this time
bro no
i i could do the ad reads yeah
oh marty i forgot i
should have definitely [ __ ] did him
first why didn't we think about that
we're sitting here we have all the time
in the world yeah
no guests today could have done it
however
all right let's get this done soon
let's knock these out now okay yeah
let's do this merry christmas guys
appreciate it merry christmas 145.
oh it's the new lights
that's what's throwing me off too i keep
seeing lights like shine over me and
it's like streaming in so uh
i forgot we have a whole [ __ ] thing
so sick
oh you're sipping on this i wish trent
would come on the podcast
he'd be he's a fool
he's a fool you'd be such a great great
conversation yeah for sure
um yeah he would be uh what time are we
at sorry 145. well 45 that's good that's
good yeah definitely
definitely feeling it i could definitely
see every spec that was not perfectly in
line of stuff
yep
it's over it's over man
i'm good but
two and a half grams is my limit when it
comes to holding a full conversation
as of right now
not great i was going to hit you with a
round of applause but i'll let that no
it's fine like i'm good
i just i could feel like that
i could feel all that like
rather be on a big-ass beanbag get up
like yeah i can feel it but i i guess
after doing this so many times i'd be
fine like josh does it every time yeah
he's
used to two and a half grams like right
now my pants feel weird
like on my i can feel like every time i
move like i feel touched my skin like
weird
why does that feel like that
i'm not tripping but yeah you guys know
what i'm telling you take mushrooms you
know what stage i'm in right now
yeah definitely definitely not driving
but um
oh and the show [ __ ] guys thank you so
much for being here thank you so much
i'm over here having a full conversation
with you
my bad uh marty anything you want to say
thank you guys again for all the love on
the april episode and the dealing with
death episode it's been a very [ __ ]
personal month here at the [ __ ]
podcast and
you guys make things a lot easier to
deal with and
we're just very excited about looking at
into this next year with all the [ __ ]
going on it's all because of you guys
we're just here just talking [ __ ]
right here just talking [ __ ]
yo i never thought
thank you guys so much for making this
my job i'm barely holding on
you're under the table yeah i'm barely
i'm barely holding on and this is our
job that's [ __ ] amazing
thank you guys for letting uh us do this
as a [ __ ] job i
yeah
it's gonna be wild in a few minutes i
can feel it [ __ ] ad reads marty damn
man
good thing you're a [ __ ] pro i'll
pull it together okay here we go ah
we're not there's no cuts in the podcast
everything i just filmed story time
right before this so i keep thinking
like cut cut i'll edit that out oh no
there's no editing
and i just started to feel like i just
started to feel nauseous
that's what i know you're good yeah
that's what i know
oh it's coming soon whenever i start to
feel a little sick i know like oh it's
digesting
that's the thing you're strapping in for
like five six hours of this [ __ ] i
didn't really i never think about it
like that i got
i thing i don't have much to do right
now
all right
here we are thank you guys so much for
hanging out thank you for watching thank
you for being here this has been the
last episode of the year this is the
dope as usual podcast
it's been fun it's not the last episode
of the year is it yeah oh
this comes out the 27th
yeah you're right yeah damn
what a [ __ ] year goddamn that didn't
really hit me that this was the year
wrap up episode [ __ ] yeah i think i said
it earlier or maybe i said it in the
story time i gotta stop filming two
things that one same day i could have
swore i just talked about all this but
that was the outro from that [ __ ]
story
that's why oh yeah finish stop [ __ ] okay
guys we've been here for now 10 months
thank you guys for being here the next
couple months or the next year is going
to be badass
marty just and i were just talking about
it we're just going to keep things to
ourselves until they happen
just so we don't get you guys hopes up
and then things don't when they fall
through so thank you guys for being here
thank you so much uh this is a
completely different wrap up i can feel
that i'm not like um on point
this might be the first time marty is
doing the ad reads we'll see we'll see
but i'm i can definitely
[ __ ] man okay thank you guys for being
here thank you this has been the
mushrooms episode whatever we're gonna
call i have no idea
thank you for being here
appreciate it uh have a dope ass day
have a have hope you had a good year
please be safe happy new year have a no
best day
whoa
perfect
perfect yeah did it [ __ ] signed up oh
my god dude i didn't think about it why
didn't we do the ads first dude
i'm barely hanging on
i'm at the point where i start just
i'm just here i'm just here
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]